Доброго вечора всім.
На війні необхідна солідарність та єдність.
Наприклад, у НАТО,
де члени альянсу фактично називають
себе партнерами.
Однак такі країни НАТО як Греція та Туреччина,
напевно, швидше ﻿назвали б одна одну ворогами.
Відносини між ними загострювалися
протягом багатьох років
через територіальні претензії у Середземному морі
чи поклади там природного газу.
Міністерка закордонних справ Бербок сьогодні
відвідала обидві країни.
Вона висловила свою солідарність з Афінами,
на яку згодом у Стамбулі
закономірно пролунало крижане відлуння.
Це тим більше складно, тому що Туреччина зараз
відіграє центральну роль у війні в Україні,
а саме в угоді про зерно.
Детальніше розповість Люк Вальпот.
Перелік тем був довгий, а тон спочатку звучав тепло.
«Мій друже Мевлюте», — саме так зверталась
Бербок до свого колеги.
Вона високо оцінила посередництво Туреччини
у зерновій угоді,
а Чавушоглу – тісні економічні відносини з Німеччиною.
Однак приховати розбіжності все ж не вдалося,
а вони істотні.
Слухати один одного, навіть якщо від цього
болять вуха, - так прокоментувала свій візит Бербок.
Наприклад, необхідно виконувати рішення
Європейського суду з прав людини.
До того ж, без винятку й у будь-який час.
Для мене це також включає звільнення Османа Кавали
за рішенням Європейського суду з прав людини.
Я розумію, що в наш час на такій пресконференції
важко говорити про теми,
які глибоко хвилюють.
Однак Чавушоглу це хвилювання не зупинило.
Інші країни, наприклад Греція, також
не виконуватимуть
рішення Суду з прав людини.
Пані Бербок приїхала прямо з Греції.
Однак вона не згадує, що Афіни протягом 14 років
зволікають з рішенням суду про захист
турецьких меншин.
Вранці в Афінах Бербок чітко дала зрозуміти,
що підтримує Грецію у суперечці між нею та Туреччиною
щодо островів в Егейському морі.
Грецькі острови, Лесбос, Кос, Родос та багато інших
є територією Греції.
І ніхто не має права ставити це під сумнів.
Це спонукало міністра закордонних справ Туреччини
недипломатично висловитися щодо Бербок.
Пані Меркель завжди була щирою посередницею.
Я у жодному разі не прошу вас
прийняти нашу точку зору,
але ми очікуємо, що Німеччина залишатиметься
неупередженою та справедливою.
Таку позицію ми б поважали.
Однак було досягнуто згоди,
що Туреччина має продовжувати
виконувати роль посередника
між Росією та Україною
з метою припинення війни.
Наслідками зусиль Туреччини стало те,
що сьогодні в Одесі завантажили зерном вантажні судна.
Президент Зеленський спеціально приїхав до порту.
Щойно ми отримаємо сигнал від ООН та Туреччини,
перше судно зможе відправитися.
Мабуть, це буде сьогодні або завтра.
Промінь надії для українців і для мільйонів людей,
які чекають зерна.
Ми знову повертаємося до Стамбула, судна із зерном
ще не вирушили з Одеси,
чи є якісь новини?
І в Одесі, і в ООН кажуть,
що залишилося вирішити ще кілька невеликих деталей.
Наприклад, фарватер, який ще не визначали на 100%,
а також замінований шлях.
Схоже, що перше судно
може відправитися зранку у вихідні
або найпізніше в неділю.
Тож Бербок схвально висловилась
щодо зернової угоди,
але в іншому було багато несумісностей.
Як ви це оцінюєте?
Так, на прес-конференції сьогодні було
дуже відверто.
Можливо, це був не дуже вишуканий шаховий крок
від міністерки закордонних справ Бербок.
Вона буквально сказала,
що дружба не означає обмінюватися банальностями.
Вона зробила чітку заяву, набагато чіткішу
ніж канцлер Шольц під час свого візиту у травні.
Між Шольцем та Ердоганом стосунки були
більш відсторонені та формальні.
Тоді вони не казали правду так прямо,
і, власне, це й було не обов'язково.
Сьогоднішні висловлювання були дуже сильними,
і це новий тон, до якого Туреччині потрібно пристосуватися.
Однак цілком можливо, що наразі це доцільно -
внести ясність,
чітко висловити свою позицію.
Це може зумовити позитивні зрушення у порівнянні
з минулими переговорами з урядом Туреччини.
Прямо зі Стамбула Люк Вальбот, дякуємо.
Місяці мовчання на офіційних каналах, але тепер
держсекретар США вперше з початку війни
провів розмову з міністром закордонних справ РФ.
Це мала бути відкрита розмова.
Держсекретар США Блінкен після розмови заявив,
що сказав Лаврову,
що світ ніколи не визнає анексію
українських територій.
Він також закликав Лаврова погодитися на пропозицію
звільнити двох громадян США,
яких затримали в Росії.
Німеччина хоче поставити Україні 16
танків-мостоукладачів Biber,
шість з них цього року.
Це уможливить пересування українських військ
через водойми та канави.
Росія та Україна звинуватили одна одну
у причетності до вибуху у місці утримання полонених
в Донецькій області.
Загинули щонайменше 50 осіб.
За даними Міноборони РФ,
це були українські військовополонені.
Для запобігання масштабних наслідків
енергетичної кризи, яка насувається,
діятимуть суворіші  правила
щодо рівня заповнення газових сховищ.
До 1 вересня вони мають бути наповненими на 75%,
а потім - на 95% до листопада.
Зараз сховища заповнені на 67%.
У липні рівень інфляції в єврозоні
досягнув нового максимуму - 8,9%.
Через війну рушійними силами цін знову стали
енергія, паливо та продовольство.
Цей показник є найвищим у країнах Балтії - понад 20%.
Економіка Німеччини на початку літа не зростала.
За даними Федерального статистичного управління,
порівняно з попереднім роком вона стагнувала.
Через реєстрацію людей, які залишили територію України,
в липні кількість безробітних зросла до 2,47 млн.
Це на 107 тисяч більше, ніж у червні.
Частка зростає до 5,4%.
Порівняно з минулим роком безробітних людей стало
на 120 тис. менше.
Англія виграла лише один міжнародний чемпіонат
з футболу у 1966 році.
Дехто з болем згадує, як вони стали чемпіонами світу
завдяки голу на стадіоні «Вембл»
не на користь Німеччини.
Після цього затишшя зберігалось до сьогоднішнього дня.
Німеччина часто вигравала матчі.
Так народився міф про непереможних німців.
Однак післязавтра англійська футбольна команда
має шанс виграти фінал Чемпіонату Європи
на тому самому стадіоні «Вембл» під час домашнього матчу.
Її супротивником буде Німеччина.
Про футбольну лихоманку Англії розповість
Андреас Штамм.
Останні штрихи перед фінальним матчем.
Тренувальне поле чимось схоже
на будівельний майданчик.
Попереду команду чекає матч на «святому місці».
Три слова, які вже давно наелектризували
футбольний світ:
Англія, Німеччина, «Вемблі».
Звичайно, ми в ейфорії та з нетерпінням чекаємо
атмосфери, виходу на стадіон та матчу
проти суперників.
Я думаю, що це буде гра,
яка не скоро повториться.
Тому й очікування величезні.
Всі чекають на супротивників - «Левиць»,
команду, яка зумовила на острові стільки ентузіазму
до жіночого футболу.
Переповнені фан-милі та паби, як у півфіналі
рекордна кількість людей на стадіонах, по телебаченню:
Це справжнє народне свято.
Не такі величезні масштаби святкування,
як під час гри чоловічої команди - поки що.
Якість гри, футбольна майстерність,
швидкість.
Більше не потрібно ховатися від чоловіків.
Плюс фантастична атмосфера.
Нуль агресії, краще, ніж на будь-якому
чоловічому матчі.
Це шалено, надихаюче та блискуче.
Я така щаслива.
Уособлення атмосфери сімейного фестивалю:
півфінальний переможний танець Тесс Долан,
який перетворив 8-річну фанатку футболу з Манчестера
в улюбленицю ЗМІ.
Команда має хороше мислення.
Вони обдумують кожен крок.
Не просто штовхають м'яч.
Цього достатньо для рахунку 3:2
не на користь Німеччини.
Але жодна інша футбольна нація не знає краще,
ніж Англія, як швидко ейфорія
може розчинитися.
Перед цим фіналом страх має назву: Попп-паніка.
Наші футболістки сильні.
Але Попп - вона дуже хоче перемоги,
це добре видно.
Все готово до фіналу
у цьому храмі спорту.
Без зайвих слів: Англія, Німеччина, «Вемблі».
Отже, лишається ще тільки прогноз погоди.
Завтра погода буде хорошою та сухою лише на
північному сході та заході.
В інших регіонах очікуються зливи та грози.
Температура буде 20-30°С.
Найближчими днями на півночі погода буде мінливою,
на півдні буде сонячно та ставатиме спекотніше,
температура досягатиме до 35°С.
Це були всі новини.
Побачимось завтра,
гарного вечора.